quedaron pendientes varios casos cerca
de 18 casos pendientes todavía tendrá
que definir la corte suprema- los nueve
magistrados de la corte suprema de aquí
a que termine el periodo este período
que determinó las próximas semanas antes
de que los magistrados salgan a
vacaciones de verano cinco casos
importantes entonces quedaron pendientes
el primero claramente el tema del aborto
el caso del aborto que ha generado
tantas manifestaciones de hecho ha
generado que precisamente tanto la corte
suprema como el capitolio vuelva otra
vez a tener mallas alrededor para evitar
las manifestaciones que se acerquen aún
a el edificio principal de la corte que
podemos ver atrás mío también está el
caso de la segunda enmienda del porte
armas en nueva york' se pretende quitar
un permiso que es muy que prohíbe que la
gente pueda adquirir licencia de armas
en nueva york' también está el caso de
el caso de quedarse en méjico un caso
migratorio que tiene pendiente el estado
de texas contra la administración de
iovine también está el tema de la
libertad religiosa y también el tema del
cambio climático se pretende que la
agencia ambiental pues pueda imponer
sanciones a las industrias energéticas
en este país cristóbal cuando entonces
se podría definir un tema como el del
aborto si ya se filtró parte de la
posición de la corte
exactamente dentro y se sabe que la
mayoría conservadora de la corte pues
apoya estas nuevas restricciones al
aborto pero como en este momento en
washington hay audiencias para el tema
del 6 de enero de la investigación del 6
de enero y el ambiente político está
bastante tenso entonces lo que está
tratando de hacer la corte suprema es
postergar esta decisión para que no se
junten protestas manifestaciones y haya
desmanes en la ciudad se presente se
espera entonces que la próxima semana o
empezando el mes de julio se conozca una
decisión sobre el aborto y sobre las
armas y el tema migratorio en eeuu para
entonces así pues evitar que haya que
haya coincidencias en temas políticos
trascendentales en morzine